doesn't feel super safe should we go all
the way to the top yeah yeah okay all
right safe safe up here good morning
John good morning well that was the most
elaborate one so far really we had like
nails and we could put it there
permanent oh don't worry he'll be he'll
be there in the back got a plan it's a
massive forehead can hold him in place
well hello Hank hi happy last day of
pizzas greetings from the tree house we
decided to do it in a tree house yeah
because that was an option we never had
a treehouse growing up
it wasn't in a tree but it was this it
was literally just this but without the
tree wrapped around yeah it was a great
place to get up to Mischief I got
grounded from that Fort did you from
throwing bottles off of it oh that's not
cool I remember doing one of my
elementary school science fairs from
that before where I counted the number
of people who drove past ice wearing
seat belts nice that's good that's great
even back then I was a big fan of
government regulations he's not gonna
make it in the video is it I think it
may Hank wants to get the light off my
face so we're doing this he's gonna be
like that and I'm gonna be like that I
always wanted he always criticizes me
for not wearing a hat yeah here I am so
earlier today Hank and I went to an art
gallery where we saw this amazing art
made entirely out of like dandelions or
daffodils or else iron oxide paints and
then we went to the IMA and saw a cool
fashion show it did it was great it's
been a good day and now we're in a
treehouse John took my phone and gave me
and like took videos so maybe I will
have put video over that I'm just trying
to get some kind of b-roll situation so
that we don't want to see me wearing
this hat you can take the hat off then
I'm all blown out which is what you're
worried about well I was thinking you
could just move a little
bit spending so listen Hank's been
raptured it's more gonna be a vlog
brother situation sorry about the wind
noise it's just Hank's getting raptured
the Rapture I want to do something
different something we've never done on
the bug with this channel before okay
I'm sorry we're trying to understand
where your son is for so long it's the
big bright thing in this guy it's really
weird that there's some maybe something
that we've never done before yeah here's
what it is it's an educational video
with both of us oh in it what are we
educating on I'm educating you on
planets I heard there are eight of them
they don't exist what this is like
yesterday when you told me that we don't
know what light is I don't this is not
going to be good for me that was with
the Nobel Prize in physics in part was
about how we don't know what light is or
even reality but we're not going to talk
about that wait what we're not gonna
talk about that we don't know why
there's matter in the universe we don't
know what light is and we don't know
what's real and we don't really know
whether time is real and fat and also it
seems like the universe is actually
two-dimensional and the third dimension
that we experience is space
is the kind that is a different kind of
Dimension which is really throwing me
for a loop but I'm doing it I know I
know I hear you I'm moving around in it
right now look at me look at three
dimensional wait I'm not
three-dimensional to them we were in
that pizza pizza that Gallery you're in
that gallery from the Sprouse guy was
his name something Sprouse Cole Sprouse
nope that's a different Sprouse those
are the Sprouse Brothers Steven Sprouse
couldn't tell you that the fashion
designer yeah yeah see what they did
we were in the Steven Sprouse gallery
and we're walking around and looking at
all these like his whole sort of Decades
of work and then uh Catherine come up to
me and I said someday it'll be like this
but just Pizza John's nothing says
future Museum fashion shows there's like
pizza Joe there's a lot of good pizza
John art it's true it's true so who
knows yeah you're right we should have
we should start a pizza John Gallery
yeah it'd be hard to get all of them
together anyway that's not what I wanted
to talk about I don't know what light is
we don't know what time is we don't know
what we're reality is but planets aren't
real planets are real obviously planets
are real in a way that any anything is
but the idea of planets isn't a true
category well I would argue that very
few categories are true categories
because there is this weird
non-one-to-one relationship between
reality and Language by the way I'm the
only one who has a face according to the
camera so I think maybe out of focus
this was my idea to film in the
treehouse so I am paying paying for it
is that the only thing you wanted to
teach me no there are things that do
have true categories like protons are
protons electrons are electrons I think
and people argue with me about it but
that life is a true category close
planets as they are defined now when we
redefined them and it excluded Pluto uh
and and that's sort of a very
contentious thing and people get upset
about it but they the reason I'm not
upset about it is because I don't think
that planets exist and I think that most
people would agree that planets don't
exist and I'd like to explain to you
some ways in which planets don't exist
okay the current set of categories that
we use is it has to be as like has to
have formed itself into a sphere which
they call hydrostatic equilibrium Pluto
is is a sphere so is Series yeah or lots
of moves but then another one is that it
has to have cleared its orbit so it has
to be big enough that like the the area
that it travels it sucked up all the
stuff in that orbit and that is just a
category we decided in order to uh make
it make it feel like there is a thing
called a planet and draw a line that
works in our solar system
but there's gonna be fuzzy Parts in
other solar systems let me tell you
another way I'm not convinced planets
exist I'm not convinced that mercury has
more in common with Jupiter than mercury
has in common with like Europa
absolutely this is one of my so I think
that a very clear distinction in our
solar system is the difference between a
gas giant and a terrestrial planet that
seems like a way bigger deal and that is
one of that is one of my Arguments for
why planets don't exist because why
would you put those two things in one
category is trying to get me just put it
on put it on it's great that's great
another thing is that uh Jupiter in
particular has these four very large
moons one of them being larger than
Mercury so it's not certainly not size
that makes a thing a planet but those
moons are going around Jupiter not
around a star you're right and that's so
that's like the final thing but if
Jupiter were 10 times bigger it would be
a star wait so there's no difference
between Jupiter and a star except for
size
yeah so imagine that world where Jupiter
is 10 times bigger all those moons are
now planets it just happened nothing
changed about them
um
but they are now planets just because
the thing that they are orbiting
happened to be more massive I think it's
really weird that we're filming this one
of our first videos ever that's in the
sun like I have a really direct view of
the sunlight and I'm suddenly aware of
the fact that I'm only here because
there is a like source of Eternal not
quite Eternal unfortunately light
shining down upon this planet that has
made all of this possible but it's also
like the one thing I can't look at
so metaphorically resident yeah the
thing that makes me possible is the
thing that is the only thing in our
natural lives that we can't look at can
we move to the other side of the tree no
no so the video is so bad this is the
bit now
this is the future is the current you
were like man I really need to be in the
treehouse video not ugly we're gonna try
it I bet you're right I bet it's just
gonna be the exact same problem this
would be the worst way for us to go
especially if we both die yeah well I
mean that way at least we don't have to
decide what to do when the other one
dies as I said it is no better over here
it's really nice it might be worse
there's so much tree around though the
visible reminder of the invisible light
shining down upon us all the time
maybe if I get in your Shadow and then
another way in which planets don't exist
is sometimes a thing that is definitely
a planet gets ejected from the solar
system and has no star anymore it could
be a gas giant it could be a terrestrial
planet but nobody would say that it's
not a planet one of my all-time favorite
memories is one time we were talking
about that phenomenon where a planet
gets ejected out from a solar system and
then the planet is just like
hurling through the vacuum of space for
oh yeah there's no daytime no night time
it's always dark on the planet and you
were like well there would be no light
so there would probably be no life and
then you paused and said unless they
made their own light
and I think about that all the time I
think phosphorescence is one of the
coolest things that we do because the
the idea of making our own light is so
beautiful like the idea of storing the
Sun's light in some indirect way and
then using it to create our own light
like fireflies do or angler fish or
whatever humans do oh yeah we do it too
we can actually make something brighter
than the sun which doesn't have never
happened on Earth until us
we did it
Joe
John is a hard time saying we did it
without saying that's true I can't it's
something I can't I cannot celebrate I
cannot celebrate any kind of Victory
because then I have to say we did it and
then I have to pause for three seconds
and say Joe you're gonna be the next
president of the United States
and I'm gonna do that like in 30 years
when people are like I don't understand
the reference I remember playing trivia
Pursuit with our parents
when we were you know teens yeah and
they would always know the vice
president like of the of the spiritual
AG new oh and I'm like how do you know
that and I'm like of course like I know
all of the vice presidents been alive
Dan Quayle is yeah sure just barely a
vice president right also just barely
still being held on to by public
knowledge oh yeah he's a no nothing
personal Dan I know you're a fan of the
of the Vlog but uh yeah he's barely
hanging on he's an Indiana boy right
some would hope a future resident of
Crown Hill Cemetery I'm glad that you're
looking out for Crown Hill John I
thought about writing about letters
saying I know you live in Arizona now
Dan but have you considered this is a
great format I think the great part is
that you can see certain parts of our
faces and I explained to you why planets
don't exist and in a similar way Pizza
also definitely doesn't exist and this
week I written these arguments about
whether a hot dog is a sandwich about
whether the ocean is soup about whether
at calzone is pizza
eh Pizza doesn't exist Hoops don't exist
the ocean kind of also doesn't exist
where's the line there's all that
brackish water with vegetarian almost
everything that we think of as
dichotomous is in fact spectral yeah I
don't like definitions that are just
lists of of categories or lists like
like ways to include and exclude certain
things right but that's a lot of the
only way to do it now you see a lot of
talk about like how fish don't exist
they don't and how trees don't exist
yeah they don't but
also if that's the way you're looking at
it basically nothing exactly but I think
the purpose of saying that these
categories aren't really real is
reminding people that there is a
difference between the way we describe
things and the way they are that like
language is inherently less Rich than
reality right at the same time we are
not gonna actually not need a bird fish
we still need language yeah yes but if
we can do this at the same time
recognize the limits of these categories
while still acknowledging their
importance in our language and in our
ability to communicate with each other I
think that that is a more interesting
discussion than whether or not Pluto
should be a planet
right but it's not as but it's not as
sticky it doesn't give people as excited
no I know they want to fight for the
thing that they had and Pluto is a great
name for a planet did you know John that
um that there are three planets that
have elements named after them actually
four but you have to be really weird to
get the fourth Mercury oh yeah you're
right there's five that was my first one
that would that would seem like a slam
dunk yeah that was an early one
um uranium yep plutonium if you count
Pluto so what's between Uranus and Pluto
neptunium that's right and they are
actually all in a line uranium neptunium
and plutonium one thing about Hank is
that even if you've seen The Tick Tock
you still have to let him finish
and then there's one other uh-huh and
I'm not gonna tell it to you oh I want
to see it in the comments that's the
business because it's a tree it's a
tricky one we're trying to drive
engagement let's end with a call to
action Hank like any good YouTuber would
it's the last day of pizza Miss
pizzamus.com Pizza doesn't exist but
Pizza Miss does oh there you go he is
wearing a pizza pizza it just hasn't
it's but he hid it away the whole time
this was a trick I wanted to make an
educational video so that we could just
have a long ass last day of Pete's in
this video or we chatted I'm sure yeah
John will continue to see you all
weekend thanks so much for having me
over and indeed the only reason we'll
continue to see each other is because of
this light
this visible sign of the invisible
vision
light
it's a cliche but you're no T.S Eliot
yeah um I don't want to hurt your
feelings but you're no tsle light the
visible reminder of the invisible
visible what is it nothing what's the
quote go Google it as T.S Eliot wrote uh
great poetry uh needed to be understood
to communicate did he something like
that
[Laughter]
get your pizza Miss rug
I think that they're on sale is a
discount
you can just hide them in the forest
hide them in the forest
how is it
uninjured all right
not bad I I was I was certain it would
be fine
yeah it's uh unlocked and I immediately
saw Kanye West's uh screenshots from
Instagram that's probably not probably
avoid that it's working